[Applaudissements]
voici ce que pékin ne veut plus voir de
vaste contestation pro-démocratie et
anti-gouvernement comme celle qui a
secoué le territoire pendant des mois
l'an dernier
une contestation largement pacifiques
parfois émaillées de violences qui
gronde toujours la chine affirme que sa
loi sera une épée suspendue au dessus de
la tête de la petite minorité qui menace
à hong kong
la sécurité nationale les autorités
pourront surveiller et mettre sur écoute
toute personne soupçonnée de poser un
tel danger
la justice chinoise sera déclarée
compétente pour les cas graves
tout acte de sécession de terrorisme de
collusion avec les forces étrangères ou
encore de subversion est passible de la
prison
les opposants à cette loi imposée par
pékin pauvre qu'elle porte une grave
atteinte à l'autonomie de leur
territoire de sept millions et demi
d'habitants
il est militant de longue date convaincu
d'être parmi les premières cibles de ce
tour de vis sécuritaire en dessous de
leur formation politique
c'est le cas de joshua wang dont le
mouvement appelle à l'autodétermination
du territoire sur twitter il réagi en
affirmant que la loi sécuritaire marque
la fin du en compte que tout le monde
connaît cette loi présenté comme
nécessaire pour restaurer la stabilité a
par contre été célébré par un petit
groupe de partisans
la chef de l'exécutif hongkongais pro
pékin coeur et l'âme a prévenu
aucune sanction ne nous fera pas les
etats unis qui sommes la chine de faire
marche arrière ont notamment commencé à
suspendre le traitement spécial qu'ils
accordent à hong kong des privilèges qui
ont permis au territoire semi-autonome
de devenir une importante place
financière internationale
le pouvoir central considère toute
critique étrangères comme une ingérence
dans un dossier intérieur des critiques
aussi venus du royaume uni est occupée
york au but suivi plus qu'une semaine de
par londres affirme que pékin a rompu sa
promesse faite hong kong et en vertu de
l'accord de rétrocession en garantissant
leurs droits et libertés que la chine
promulguer cette loi avec une rapidité
après sa présentation
est ce la veille du 23e anniversaire de
la rétrocession jette de l'huile sur le
feu dans ce contexte tendu et incertain
des militants comptent des filets ce 1er
juillet comme chaque année défiant ainsi
une interdiction de manifester et posé
officiellement pour deux raisons de
collier 19,6 yannick bureau radio-canada
séoul